-Senate Republicans
have all but completed
their cover-up for
the president's crimes
as they blocked witnesses
and moved to acquit him.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Donald Trump is not just
a very dumb man.
He's also a very weird man.
He definitely believes things
that are dumb,
but he also believes things
that are weird and dumb.
First, there are your garden
variety dumb things,
like yesterday,
when he congratulated
Super Bowl champions, the
Kansas City Chiefs on Twitter
and said, "You represented
the great state of Kansas,
and, in fact,
the entire USA very well,"
which would have been fine,
expect the Chiefs are based
in Kansas City, Missouri.
Now, I know it's confusing that
there are to two Kansas Cities
to a middle schooler who is
just finding out about it.
But I guess we can't expect the
president of the United States
to track of all the states.
I mean, he knows that the red
ones are the ones that like him,
and Florida is the one
that looks like a penis.
And Trump really
can keep being dumb
because there's no cost
from his base.
Trump supporter and head of
the American Conservative Union,
Matt Schlapp tweeted,
"Dear East Coast Establishment,
Kansas City, Kansas,
is in Kansas,"
which is true, but that's not
we're the Chiefs play,
so it's irrelevant.
That would be like me saying
Matt Schlapp sounds like slang
for the sound it makes
when you fart in yoga class.
[ Laughter ]
Irrelevant.
Now, those are the standard
sorts of dumb things
we're accustomed to hearing
from our president.
But then there are
the weirder dumb things.
For example, here's a weird
dumb thing Trump believes.
He seems to think that
stealth military jets
which use technology
to avoid detection by radar
and other means are literally
invisible to the naked eye.
It's something he's said
many times,
including in a speech
in Michigan last week.
-I know everybody here
in Michigan
supports our great armed forces
as much as any place. Michigan.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that's why we're giving
strong consideration
to deploying some
of our mighty F-35s
to Selfridge Air National
Guard Base.
And you know what that means,
right?
You know what that means.
That's a big deal.
So Selfridge, you're gonna see
a lot of very fast planes.
Actually,
they're totally stealth.
So maybe you won't see them
come in.
Okay? You won't see them
come in, but they're coming in.
-He genuinely thinks
stealth means invisible.
His brain is only capable
of thinking in cartoons.
He actually believes
the military has developed
the same technology
as Wonder Woman.
[ As Trump ] Our great soldiers
are out there fighting ISIS
with their bracelets
and golden lassos.
[ Normal voice ] Honestly,
there's a good chance
we could prank Trump
by leading him down a jetway
and telling him, "Mr. President,
we would like you to be
the first man to board
the invisible F-35 jet,
and then just watch him fall
face first onto the runway.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you know what sound it would
make when he hit the tarmac?
Matt Schlapp!
[ Laughter ]
Then on Friday,
Trump gave another speech
where he did his usual schtick
of bragging about stuff
he hasn't actually done,
like, for example,
the jobs numbers.
But he also decided to give
his daughter Ivanka
a shout-out, as well.
Now, as you watch this clip,
just remember that about
6.7 million jobs
have been created
during Trump's PRESIDENCY.
And, hey, while that's great,
it's also incidentally lower
than the 8 million jobs
created in roughly the same
period of time
at the end of Barack Obama's
presidency.
Just remember, that's how many
jobs Trump and Obama created
in roughly three years each --
about 14.7 million combined.
Now here's the president
on Friday
talking about how many jobs his
daughter has supposedly created.
-Ivanka's been a champion
for administrative
and legislative actions
to combat human trafficking
and a true heart.
This issue has been
so important to her.
This, and making sure people
are ready to work.
And she's now created over
15 million jobs
for the people of our country,
one of the reasons
our employment numbers
are the best ever.
15 million.
-She's created 15 million jobs?
I don't even know
what her job is!
I mean, I think she works
with at risk teens.
I don't -- At this point,
I don't think he's even
consciously making up
these numbers.
I think they randomly
pop into his head
like those ping-pong balls
they use in a lottery.
[ As Trump ] Tonight's
Mega Millions numbers
are 1, 5, million.
[ Laughter ]
This is the deranged mind
of an addled man
who is incapable of wielding
the tremendous power he holds.
Republicans are deeply committed
to allowing him
to keep that power
by any means necessary.
Take Senator Lamar Alexander,
for example.
He was considered
a possible swing vote
for allowing additional
witnesses,
but ended up voting against it.
And on Sunday,
Alexander was asked
if by quitting Trump,
he would be emboldening
the president to once again
seek foreign interference
to cheat in an election,
something Trump has already
done twice now,
and Alexander insisted Trump
wouldn't do it again.
-Are you at all concerned,
though,
when you seek foreign
interference,
he does not believe he has done
anything wrong,
that what has happened here
might encourage him
that he can continue to do this?
-I don't think so. I hope not.
I mean, enduring an impeachment
is something that nobody
should like.
Even the president said he
didn't want that on his résumé.
I don't blame him.
So if a call like that
gets you an impeachment,
I would think he would think
twice before he did it again.
-Think twice?
He doesn't even think once!
He's like one of those
single celled organisms
that only reacts to light
and heat.
But as the vote to acquit Trump
approaches on Wednesday,
this is the argument Republicans
have arrive at.
They literally just don't care,
even if there are more witnesses
who can attest to Trump's
criminality.
For example, on Friday, we
got yet another bombshell leak
from a manuscript written
by Trump's former
National Security Advisor,
John Bolton.
Trump told Bolton directly
that he wanted to force Ukraine
to dig up dirt on Democrats.
-Ambassador John Bolton claims
President Trump's
pressure campaign on Ukraine
began much earlier
than was previously reported.
The "New York Times" reports
"President Trump
directed John Bolton,
then his
National Security Advisor,
to help with his pressure
campaign
to extract damaging information
on Democrats
and Ukrainian officials."
The article goes on to say
Mr. Trump gave the instruction
Mr. Bolton wrote during
an oval office conversation
in early May that included
the acting White House
Chief of Staff, Mick Mulvaney,
the president's personal lawyer,
Rudolph Giuliani,
and the White House Counsel,
Pat Cipollone,
who is now leading the
president's impeachment defense.
-Think about that --
Trump literally said the crime
he was doing out loud
in the Oval Office,
and there were
multiple witnesses.
At least Nixon tried to keep
his tapes secret.
If Trump had tapes, he'd be
selling them in Times Square.
[ As Trump ] Guys,
check out my mixtape.
There's more where
that came from.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Now,
as a side note here,
I just want to say
the way Bolton has handled this
has been gross.
He was already a bad guy,
but now he's selectively leaking
damning evidence
of the president's criminality
just to sell a book
instead of coming forward and
telling everyone what he knows.
If you know someone
who's planning to rob a bank,
you call the cops immediately.
You don't wait a year
and then publish a book
called, "Remember That Bank That
Got Robbed? I Knew About It."
[ Laughter ]
But still, now we know
not only did Trump say
what the crime was, there were
multiple people present.
Senate Republicans could have
called any of these guys
to testify --
Bolton, Mulvaney, Giuliani,
and yet they voted not to
hear from any of them.
Here's how Alexander explained
his vote to block witnesses
during an interview with NPR.
-I don't need to hear
any more evidence
to decide that the president did
what he's charged with doing.
So if you've got eight witnesses
saying that you
left the scene of an accident,
you don't need nine.
-Instead,
that's not what happened.
It's more like Trump
caused the accident
by driving his golf cart
through the front door
of a Wendy's,
stayed at the scene
of the accident
eating fries off of other
people's plates,
called a press conference,
bragged that it was
a perfect accident,
then tweeted in all caps,
"NO COLLISION."
[ Laughter ]
And other Republicans quickly
joined in on the cover-up.
Alaska senator Lisa Murkowski
admitted in a statement
that "I have come
to the conclusion
that there will not be
a fair trial in the Senate."
And Florida senator Marco Rubio
said,
"Just because actions
meet a standard of impeachment
does not mean it is in the best
interest of the country
to remove a president
from office.
Think about that -- they're
literally just announcing it
to the world,
"We're doing a cover-up.
We won't hold a fair trail,
and even if he's guilty,
we won't remove him
from office."
They might as well
come out and say,
"Remember all that confetti
from the Super Bowl?
Those were documents from
the White House we shredded.
See, this one says,
'Let's do crimes.'"
But the most shameless response
to the vote on Friday
came from Senator Lindsay Graham
who celebrated the GOP cover-up
with some colorful language
on Fox News Friday night.
-You know what I believe
about all this?
It was a bunch of partisan
bull[bleep] in the House,
it continued in the Senate.
It's gonna end Wednesday.
The president is gonna get
acquitted.
And it's gonna blow up
in their face.
-[ Antebellum accent ] Why
Lindsay Buckingham Beauregard
Montgomery Longstry
Winchester Graham,
you mind your tongue!
Need I to remind you, you are
on the airwaves
of a decent, all-American family
channel called Fox News,
the network of such stand-up
personalities
as Roger Ailes, Bill O'Reilly,
and America's Screamheart,
Jeanine Pirro.
[ Normal voice ] The GOP
cover-up and the likely vote
to acquit Trump on Wednesday
should seal it once and for all.
The Republican Party
is totally and completely
devoted to a corrupt imbecile
who thinks planes are invisible
and doesn't know
there are two Kansas Cities.
All Republicans care about
is clinging to power.
Their supposed respect for
the founders and the rule of law
was a fraud and a scam.
And every time they lecture
the rest of us
about the sanctity of
the Constitution, it was all...
-Bull[bleep]
This has been a "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪